hello and welcome to see you play I am
sama kido Caprio okay let's try this oh
it goes with b5 this is one of the
better replies against the snider three
g3 opening its am quite reliable
actually okay so let me think about this
I once analyzed movie for a d4 and
disposition sounds funny but I really
did hmm I don't actually remember how it
went yeah this is interesting if I was
interesting but I have every air for God
zondervan the finer points so in this
case I should probably just play
something something normal and see what
happens okay
idea here is to try to do something
against the b5 pawn it's not not that
easy to do something substantial but I'm
trying
yeah I think you can just play Bishop c6
yeah okay yeah I can't do much here
really cannot default Depot it's not
even not even easily playable here in
this position yeah but after have to do
something him
yeah it wasn't exactly that wasn't a
success yeah without t4 i'm running out
of ideas here and so let's go with this
ok interesting ok I think I have to take
this is a lot better than advancing a 92
so at least that c4 is under some
pressure and you cannot easily play
before ok so wants the gunite 35 I guess
94 95 oh yeah not greater it wasn't good
didn't play that well okay you will
probably do 95 yeah I'm Jojo bring the
night around he is f5 now actually ok I
have 95 on that so it's not not fatal
you should try to get rid of that knight
on d5 it's really an annoying piece yeah
i mean here I always have come to play
against e5 this is not not that
threatening I think ok 93 wants to
capture ok no but i actually have 95 i
can take take take stinks i can take on
c3 which is hmm yeah but it's it's okay
i think
ok so let's come f2
yeah wants to come at 5pm make some
sense of course so yeah how to play this
now it's it's tough to get rid of that
get rid of the Queenie and disposition
time morning it is Matias night g2m
possibly rookie three
you let's see that I can get some
counter play him
she'll not especially great this game
right hope I can get the C porn I can
not be sick son is coming
Jim a bit of a shame i am i cannot get
this pawn the OS has some way to get it
I groups III Roxy one and you know I get
the poem OIC going for see going for
some Bishop c5 at the end no
check check sure what a bad game I
really had no nothing araya check very
weird check I don't know someone nothing
went right in this game check like four
hits on time very strange yeah i mean i
had nothing out of the opening but i
didn't feel that the position was so
terrible I mean around here and this
this cannot be particularly great for
black is better but I don't think I
should lose that is pretty bad it is
pretty bad and after the trades already
should be okay i think as d 5 is weak
but maybe i can can never get to it
that's possible now it's all good moves
on between our three is strong it's
really difficult to get something going
here it actually didn't see that the
porn was hanging I mean this is a stir
the worst part yeah I don't know I kind
of just played moves without a
particular idea endures in this position
I wanted to try something against b5
never materializes Kim yeah the position
is just not good you could have played
be four of course this is a lot stronger
this is this move him that was just a
bad game by me I think here this
shouldn't be too bad but i'm not i'm not
playing it playing it well the whole
game was just barely played i went here
the engine wants to play this one
that makes some sense
and it's just good fun the SD 5 and so
on just a just a bad game just to bed
game on my pod okay thanks for watching